[Music]
and what do you think news I don't know
you think submitted by JK come to Texas
I liked SS cracker barrel the year a
woman freaked out over her hobby lobby's
raw cotton display
I like Hobby Lobby Michaels oh it's a
hobby store yeah but that like you buy
models and the airplanes to really get
at me so funny I'm missing your store is
a sports store huh what is it called
honey baloney
yes you like that what is it what is it
it's just like a hobby store like a
would he call it like a Michael yeah
craft store I think they have like um
other stuff besides just we also have
home decor yeah sounds like a fun place
to shop a lobby sounds very yeah yeah so
this woman she posted on Facebook this
goes on to hobby lobby's Facebook so
would you like to read this stick or is
wrong on so many levels
there is nothing decorative about raw
cotton what a commodity which has gained
was gained at the expense of African
American slaves a little sensitivity
goes a long way please remove this decor
that's it that's it that's a stretch
that's a bit of a stretch that's like
every time I see a silk robe on I'll be
[ __ ] pissed I'm actually really
curious about the cotton what do you use
that for for crafts it's just yeah it's
just the core so you're just kind of
like the plant that's behind you is just
decorative
so there's I spied upon the wall yeah or
like you know like the plant that's
literally behind you yeah yeah you just
would display it yeah so you see that at
the store right so you buy a news / here
yeah
so the cotton I just buyers put right
there wherever you want to put it ever
complained then her complaint is
basically she has a problem with the way
cotton actually grows in in nature yeah
pretty much
she has a problem with Hobby Lobby
selling it before like it's just the
fact that they're selling this and this
is there and she have a problem with
clothes cuz yeah water
with them I guess cuz it's not on the
sound I guess the big triggers something
with her like with you know slaves
picking the cotton yeah that's a stretch
though that's that's like me hating
charcoal wait
cuz coal mining yeah Chinese Asian had
to be dynamite guys yeah yeah
I hate railroads every time I see a
railroad I just get foreigner
yeah I think it I think it just upsets
me too that like people just assumed the
worst of people cuz it's literally just
like you said it's just something in its
raw form like that's it why you got to
think like the work because if I saw how
no like what some racist Asian [ __ ]
besides like railroad that if somebody
put [ __ ] rice kernels on the wall I
would like that's [ __ ] stupid that's
a meal but I wouldn't be like you know I
mean I want to get like angry about it
or oh you know what there's a lot of
like bamboo [ __ ] oh yeah bamboo [ __ ] on
everybody's long people are doing it
doesn't even look really ages that's
look at those foods you [ __ ] monster
i guess 'sir it's like it has to be
something that has to do with like
slavery so what were aging so if i see
wrong go like this don't you ever have a
[ __ ] why don't you ever in your house
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know
Oh what about when they have all these
pet calls I'm trying to like tantalize
you make you hungry I'm getting upset
that you named your kid charlie how
[ __ ] dare you need them Charlie do
you know what Charlie's are you know
they came out in the Vietnam War and
they started calling the Vietnamese
people like with the enemy they call
them Charlie's for some reason yeah
that's not even back it was like Charlie
this Charlie that and Asians got pissed
off about it I think it's one of those
things where it's like one crazy doesn't
represent hope yeah a whole group so
like she's just getting a lot of [ __ ]
attention yeah this was what she wanted
probably was it or did you post as a
joke onto hobby lobby's Facebook page
she got it wasn't it she was shoes and I
feel like she did it to get attention I
think that would you know it's like that
whole city is that that whole situation
of like the boy who cried wolf you keep
calling out [ __ ] so much real
problems don't get lit up like they're
supposed to yeah and this is one of
those situations and I think that's why
people get mad
because when a real problem happens
they'll bring this up well you guys
complain about everything so you're not
really doing anything for the culture
that's true cuz then if someone like
gets shot under racial circumstances now
it's like being overshadowed by
something stupid like stupid like for
example when I what's that what's that
one dude who stepped down from that
Marvel role so an aged person can take
that oh yeah yeah that's cried so people
got mad because Daniel Dae Kim got put
for those but he's not Japanese who the
[ __ ] cares yeah like we're talking about
Asian represent and this is the bottom I
dislike too because you're just trying
to stay together as a group and then we
could win those battles later is that
baby stuff it takes time you know you
know it's funny too is you don't see
black people you don't see brown people
and brown people I see Hispanics Middle
Eastern yeah everyone no one complains
about the roles that they get like I
watched like you know cartel films like
movies like movies about the Mexican
cartel or whatever half those actors are
all from Britain they're from the Middle
East you know they're not even of
Hispanic descent you know it's like they
don't complain you know and the public
doesn't care and no one complaints about
to put the moment Asians Korean planner
Chinese Chinese planner Japanese it's
like what thought awesome for too much
now you said something so much like I
say like back then too in Fast and
Furious Johnny Tran was played by a
Korean guy no one said [ __ ] so why are
people complaining now yeah not even
asking for too much it's not the time
like that you don't you don't when you
barely have our [ __ ] foot in the door
and you're still you're complaining
about something that should not be
talked about right now we had a guy who
a white guy whatever the culture is they
make him step down he did cook you know
thanks for that whatever but we have an
affluent good actor Daniel Dae Kim is a
good [ __ ] actor and he took over that
role I'm happy nude I'm super happy but
then you're just gonna complain about
this little thing you know he's not
actually Japanese well guess what the
whole point of this is that I think
Asian people are so separated we hear
tethers so much it's got to come
together as a group that's why even me
like I I hate a lot on a lot of Asian
film but I'll still go watch to support
it I don't have to like it but I'll
still support it yeah that's true yeah I
think yeah it's someone who can calm is
gonna be like yeah David of course
you're right because he's Korean your
Korean tip yeah but he's just a dope
back though man
you like I saw him on lost without a
terrible show I think in the G dude
there's actually not that many great
Asian actors right now that are getting
the limelight so like whoever is our
best no matter what who the [ __ ] they
are they should be yeah we should push
it down more eyes got to be on him yeah
you know that guy he was also on his
name was like miles back I completely
forgot about him but he plays like that
porcupine guy in x-men he like back
there too oh yeah he's a rush hour
dude he's dope man he played himself in
the way he speaks is so [ __ ] smooth
man I love that guy I really know he's
been around for a mini there's no shine
dude I [ __ ] love that guy like I'm
when I saw him like towards the lighter
the season of lost I was like dude this
guy's [ __ ] you know what movie I
really want to see if his it the one
where he's up acting as the love
interest opposite hayden Panettiere
oh really yeah he has a it's like
Shanghai a girl or something like that
which sounds super [ __ ] raised I
wanna watch it though and I see what
that was all about my mind is blown and
not realized I was Jintao now that I see
you as I close [ __ ] it is him I just
really hated his powers and the next me
just yeah but he would poke the [ __ ] out
of him buddy it would mildly
inconvenient someone there's the
ultimate anti-wrinkle ax owns a top
commit well this is the first thing that
pops so now the very image of cotton is
racist really people who owns a cotton
t-shirt you racist cotton undergarments
you bigot get a real life with real
problems people exactly yes there's got
people commenting on top to tell me to
shut the hell up
of course like you know like I said it
doesn't help the culture so it's like
you know you don't want people to make
your culture look stupid either so I'm
pretty sure everybody's to come together
and you shoot this woman down just like
yeah we got real problems out here let's
move along you know I'm still really
interested in the cotton is real I got
pinched
what you could do with that cotton I
think it's like it's like dried flowers
a guy he can't get it you don't even
look at it see it you know what we walk
into like a Michaels right we see a bowl
full of wire balls oh my god that's so
why yeah what is that that's what makes
it so hard for me to decorate like well
how the [ __ ] do I want this in my room
to bag a mosque a mosque that's the girl
that has a [ __ ] little bandana with
like cat ears and a whole fine edge
functional though and she bought it that
way she can make it
yeah it's functional but if it's
something that's just sitting there like
just like you good at that it's
functional in a psychological oh because
I understand it not because like I'm
like my house feels so [ __ ] amazing I
[ __ ] love I feel happy here every
home you see a face with sticks yeah
yeah like I feel like IKEA one yeah so I
want to go about this like fight
somebody with it haha four swords and
then the cats like playing with them see
there's a perfect I have a happy gift
every Asian kid hates that base because
they don't get the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's why take all the sticks up snap
them hood what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] links in the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]